this is a production of cornell
university
okay
i'm kind of lonely up here after the
whole scholarship family's cleared out
someone walked in right now they think i
smell really bad and you all just like
cleared out the front rows
so
i want to talk to you today about food
the back of the t-shirts say uh
4-h feeding the future
why does that matter
why do we need to feed the future
why does food matter
i need to have a question how many of
you in the last 24 hours have taken part
in an agricultural act raise your hand
that's awesome
i i don't normally get that that's a lot
of hands keep your hands up for a second
because i gotta
what was your agricultural act in the
pink t-shirt
ate dinner that's a good answer right
now i want to hear some other answers
what did you do
this is farming definitely an
agricultural act i have one more hand an
agricultural act would you do
it's planned in mushrooms certainly an
agricultural act
i want to get back
get back to your answer
she said she ate dinner
what's agricultural about that she
didn't farm she didn't plant anything
she didn't water anything
let's see another raise of hands how
many people have eaten food in the last
24 hours
there we go there we go
that's
that's why food matters because of her
answer right there
because eating
is an agricultural act
food matters because we eat three times
a day and three times a day we're
connecting to the land
and sometimes that connection that
relationship is a really really good one
it's healthy it's clean
sometimes it's a really really bad one
it's a twisted relationship
food is at the heart of the biggest
crises we face today
take three the three of the big crises
we face today the health crisis the
economic crisis and the energy crisis
in 2009 more people than ever before in
history died of starvation
that same year in 2009
more people than ever before in history
were diagnosed as morbidly obese
that's an imbalance
four of the top 10 killers in the united
states are diet-related diseases stroke
cancer heart disease type 2 diabetes
food
is at the heart of the health crisis
every year we spend 100 billion dollars
on diet related preventable illnesses
over 10 years if that number doesn't
increase at all that's a trillion
dollars on preventable diet related
um
illnesses and that's that's that brings
us to the economic crisis we're spending
a huge amount of money
on a food system that doesn't work
and then finally the energy crisis
uh the biggest contributor to greenhouse
gases in our economic sector is the food
system the food industry
there's a great story about about how we
move food around the world
every year we import
50 000 boxes of cookies from denmark
which kind of makes sense because you
know the danes they know how to make
cookies they eat a lot of tea they're
probably a really good recipe for
cookies so it's okay that we import at
least 50 000 boxes of cookies from
denmark every year
but at the same time every year we
export 40 000 boxes of sugar cookies to
denmark
a guy from the world bank suggested that
maybe we just swap recipes
we're spending a huge amount of energy
on shipping food back and forth all over
the world
so
and all of those crises fit under one
heading one that's close to home for me
uh the most important to me which is the
environmental crisis
and again that's why food matters three
times a day we eat food and three times
a day by eating food we're connected to
the land and sometimes we're doing that
by eating a carrot that our friends grew
for us his backyard and sometimes we're
doing that by eating a tomato that was
grown in chile
so that's why food matters
but i want to back up a bit
there's this whole you're spending the
next few days talking about feeding the
future and you're talking about your
careers and you're looking forward to
the future hopefully you're learning
some skills that you'll take home
and use to change your community and
ultimately the people that leave this
room in this conference
are going to think about changing their
communities and changing the world
i was in the garden the other day at
garden
and a little kid was a fourth grader he
looked up at me
out of nowhere out of the blue and he
said
he said can one kid change the world
i don't really know what to say partly
because i'm used to getting questions
like how big is an inch or is this a
tomato plant and so the whole like
changing the world question kind of
threw me for a loop
but also i realized that no one's ever
asked me that before i'm talking all the
time about making change
and no one's ever asked me if one kid
could change the world
so i haven't been able to stop thinking
about that question over the last few
days
i want to tell you a story
and my story
is really about a story about a garden
but it doesn't start in a farm or in the
kitchen or
anywhere else you might expect for
someone talking about food and farming
my story about a garden starts at a pond
near my house i grow i live in rural
western massachusetts and as a kid i
spent all my time at this pond
collecting bugs and frogs and all kinds
of weird insects
and i fell in love with the natural
world
and
as i got older it became a love of
biology of study of experimenting of
collecting weirder weirder insects and
doing weirder and weirder things with
them lost a lot of friends that way
and
and then in eighth grade i saw a movie
called an inconvenient truth which some
of you may have heard of
and i saw that movie and i realized that
all these things i cared so much about
were in peril were in danger
and
and so coming into high school i was all
worked up i was like oh i love the
natural world so much
and it's all in danger what am i going
to do i'm going to come into high school
i'm going to save the world it's going
to be great but then my older brother
gave me a book called an omnivore's
dilemma and the underworld
and this book was about food
and it was about how farms
was exactly the three things i talked
about before how farms were at the heart
of these issues how the way we grow food
when it's done badly destroys the planet
when it's done well can save the planet
and so i came into high school realizing
that food could save the world
and uh
and what happened was i was a freshman
in high school and you guys all some of
you may be freshman high school all some
of you may have one point have been
freshman in high school maybe even a few
of you are going to be freshman high
school when you're a freshman you're
you're ready to make do big things and
so i had this idea that i was going to
get all the food from my cafeterias to
come from local farms
and
when i would drive by my school i'd
notice all the land around our school
and i think oh maybe we'd have a little
garden like maybe the size of you know a
quarter of this of this stage
and i started talking to some friends uh
these two girls natalie and sarah and
the more we talked more we thought
why not make it a bigger garden like a
really big art like maybe even a farm
and well instead of getting all the food
from local farms why don't we just grow
all the food for our cafeterias
and that's what we did
and so much happened so fast that uh
that sometimes i forget the most
important thing that happened
was
well we faced a lot of doubt because we
were high schoolers and you guys know
high schoolers we're lazy we can't
follow through on everything on anything
we we play video games all day right we
don't do anything right
so
no so uh
so we faced a lot of doubt because we
were warned that the school committee
would tell us we couldn't use the land
we called farmers who said we were
biting off way more than we could chew
we're told we're getting in over our
heads
but
despite all that doubt
we did something important
we decided we were going to do it
no matter what no matter what people
said we decided we were going to grow
this garden
and sometimes that first step is the
hardest of all maybe it's because we
were really excited
maybe it was because we were a little
naive
since then i've learned how easy it can
be to get discouraged
to give up or let go of something
and i've learned because of that that if
you can take that first step that you
can decide you're going to do something
no matter what
the rest becomes a lot easier
so anyway so after a few months of
designing the yearly plans for our
garden
and fundraising
raising money writing grants
we planted a 3 500 square foot garden
over that first summer we donated over a
thousand pounds of produce to low-income
shelter families around the area into
shelters
we brought in kindergarten classes to
learn in the garden
we taught high school biology classes in
the garden and when we came back to
school
in the fall we tried our salads out in
the cafeterias
then over the last two three grown two
growing seasons
we've tripled the size of the garden
it's now 12 000 square feet
we've also put in 26 ireland fruit trees
built two sheds and a full-size
greenhouse
we now have every day multiple classes
come down from all three schools in our
district to learn in the garden
in the fall we do three days a week in
all three cafeterias we serve our
vegetables
and in the spring we do two days a week
and we're about to start we've raised
over 80 000 in the last four years
and
in the beginning we had three kids
involved we've now have we now have a
board of 12 students and
an advisory board of over 100.
so
that's my story
it's pretty simple
which is kind of why
no applause yet that's why it doesn't
even deserve
please it's really easy to listen to
pause that applause because you don't
know about all the horrible mistakes we
made which way outnumbering
the successes
so that story is simple
and that's why i was kind of thrown when
this kid turned up to me and said can a
kid change the world
um
can one kid change the world
i was thinking about what's happened
over the last four years and actually
the drive from my house to cornell is
pretty lengthy so i had a lot of time to
uh to think about this question
and
i think i have an answer
my answer is that first
changing the world
has to happen
one carat at a time
it's messy
you make mistakes
it's slow it's tedious it's tiring
that first year i told you um we got
classes to come down to the garden but
it didn't happen like that it wasn't
that easy what happened was all the
faculty were like no way we're
overloaded we have too much to do
there's no way we're adding extra stuff
on our plates to bring kids down to some
garden so we're like okay okay that's
fine we understand we have a lot to do
so what we did was at the beginning of
every week we went to all the mailboxes
in the in the faculty lounge and each
week we put a different vegetable in the
mailbox so
the first week we filled all the
mailboxes with cherry tomatoes and the
second week we filled all the mailboxes
with carrots and week by week
nothing happened no response people ate
the carrots the tomatoes the radishes
but eventually one teacher said hey
thanks so much for all those uh all
those vegetables and you know i was
thinking i might bring my class down to
the garden is that cool you guys were
like sure
and then a few days later another
teacher said hey you know my friend went
out of the garden you know mrs sullivan
and uh
she said it was great can i bring my
class down to the garden
and like i said now we every day we have
multiple classes working in the gardens
it's slow it's tedious it's one
vegetable at a time
the same thing happened with our
cafeteria we were determined we had this
dream of getting our food in the
cafeterias and we thought it'd be easy
you know you just grow the food you
bring it up to the cafeteria and they
serve
no it doesn't happen right now
the head of the food service program
kathy
was not happy she is used to just
heating up packaged foods that are
frozen and that's all she has to do
there was no way she was going to take
dirty crooked vegetables and have to
wash them and cut them and prepare them
there's no way she's going to do that
so every week that first year we emailed
my friend natalie emailed her with a
list of what we had so every every
saturday she'd email her and say we have
this many pounds of greens this many
pounds of carrots this many tomatoes and
every week kathy would write back and
say sorry not interested we don't want
to use your produce and every week
natalie would say okay that's fine and
the following week she would send her
the list again finally after about four
or five weeks of this happening i think
kathy was just fed up with it she was
like okay fine we'll try a salad we'll
take some of your greens we'll take some
of your cucumbers we'll do one salad in
the lunches and i'm sure in her head
that was it then we'd give up and we'd
be satisfied you know us high schoolers
so easily satisfied
and uh
and what happened was that day we came
early at six a.m we harvested tons of
food we brought it up to the cafeteria
we announced it on the loudspeakers you
know today the food that you guys grew
in the garden
uh is is gonna be in the cafeterias in
the form of south
and in our school on an average day
the cafeteria sells between four and six
salads
that day yeah kind of rough huh that day
with the project sprout food they sold
over seven
and kathy was hooked
and again like i said now we serve our
food three days a week in the cafeterias
it takes patience
it takes understanding that it's not
gonna happen like like right away it's
gonna happen slowly it's gonna take a
lot of people saying no over and over
and over again it's going to have to
happen one care at a time
the second thing that change in the
world takes is gardening in the rain
two years ago 2009 i don't know if you
guys remember or heard about it but
there's something called 350 day
and a 350 day was supposed to be the
biggest day of environmental action in
history it was organized in the fall
and people from all over the world
we're going to gather and hold up signs
and gather and big
masses and write out the number 350
which is an important number in terms of
parts per carbon in the atmosphere
and it was really exciting i helped
organize an event in my town um that was
going to happen we're all going to
organize and do something to do the
number 350.
and it was a saturday and saturdays are
our work days and so that saturday we
were also planning to build our
greenhouse
we had gotten a grant for seven thousand
dollars to build this greenhouse we were
really excited because it was going to
allow us to grow our food for the
cafeteria even in the winter but it was
fine because i was going to show up at
the garden at seven in the morning we're
all going to build the greenhouse be
done by three o'clock and then i was
going to go to this really exciting
event and uh
for the 350 day
we get to the garden and first of all
it's pouring rain it's like 40 degrees
and just pouring
we started out with like 30 volunteers
which is great
but by like 10 a.m it's down to five
o'clock because people were sick and
coughing and cold and uncomfortable
and we were missing all kinds of parts
everything was missing things were
mismatched the drill didn't work the
generator didn't work it was just all
falling apart by 12 o'clock we had
gotten one tiny hoop up for the entire
hoop house
by three o'clock when i was supposed to
be leaving for this really exciting 350
day it was down to three volunteers and
we were about halfway done
by seven o'clock the sun was going down
and we were putting together the last
few pieces
of the hoop house
we got it done i went home i was
exhausted my pants were ripped i was
covered in mud
and my hands were numb
and i just fell asleep
i woke up the next morning and my email
was flooded with emails from these
organizations all over the world with
pictures saying you know
yesterday was the most important day in
the history of environmental action
you know everyone will be telling their
grandkids about this the day we all
stood you know together you know for
this for the environment
and there were emails from people in my
community oh where were you yesterday it
was so awesome is the best day in the
history of great barrington you know
what a wonderful day
and i kicked myself
because i spent the day
struggling in the cold and mud to get up
together this hoop house i kicked myself
from missing what could have been the
most important day in my life as a as an
environmental activist
some days
we'll be rewarded
with pats in the back congratulations
people tell us how proud they are of us
what a good job we did
but most days we'll struggle in the mud
when no one is watching
most days we'll argue with people about
the value of local food or the
environment
most days we won't get rewarded with
pats on the back we'll just work and no
one will notice
and
it'll be worth it
if i could go back that day and leave
the garden at three o'clock and go to
this 350 thing and not finish the hoop
house i wouldn't
because we're not one step closer to
serving our food year round in high
school cafeteria
sure everyone else will be telling their
grandkids about the time they
they you know stood up and with 350
people and all over the world
and celebrated this day but i'll tell my
grandkids about the time i
stood knee deep in mud screwing together
a few pieces of metal
to change the world you have to be
willing to garden in the rain
and finally
and by far
most importantly
to change the world we need kids
i i have a strict rule i don't do talks
in the summer i'm really
i'm a farmer i'm not a speaker and so in
the summer it's time for working in the
garden working on the dairy farm it's
not time for speaking
but it's june 28th and i'm here
and that's because this is a room full
of kids high schoolers
um
you know there's the
this is my this is the end of my time of
project crowd i just graduated and so
leading up to the lack in the last few
weeks i was determined to make it be the
best kickoff to a growing season ever
and i just thought if this growing
season could get off to a good start
then project sprout would be fine for
the for the rest of its time and they
wouldn't need me and everything would go
smoothly and a few weeks ago things were
not going smoothly
we had to build all 100 beds and we
hadn't even started we were weeks behind
schedule and everything was just going
work
and uh
and so one day finally
we're still behind but we're going to
get started and build a few beds and me
and my friend lauren went to the garden
to build the beds and we were there we
got out our shovels five minutes later
lauren is like oh man i got bad news we
forgot we have a meeting for our
fundraiser today we can't start on the
beds
so i was like okay fine fine we'll put
the shovels away
now right then i see a car pulling up to
the garden
and at first i don't recognize the car
and then i realized what it is is the
car of this kid's short this kid george
cocafer
and george copeford is captain of the
basketball team he's a junior
and uh he's never been to the garden
and i was sure i would never see him in
the garden
george coker pulls up and he gets out of
his car and he goes hey guys what's up
uh i have a doctor's appointment a
little bit i'm here to help i got some
time to kill
and we're like sorry george but uh we're
leaving we actually got to pack up good
stuff to do maybe next time thanks for
stopping by
and george looked at us for a second
he's like not really though i i have
some time to kill can you just leave me
a shovel and i'll dig a few beds
so we said okay we gave him a shovel and
we left
and lauren and i went to our meeting and
our meeting was about two hours long and
about 6 30 we leave the meeting
and lauren's like oh man i forgot my
cell phone at the garden we got to go
back so we drive back garden and as
we're pulling up
i see george coke for his car
and i get out of the car and i look up
and sure enough there's george kochefer
at the up at the other end of the garden
working on his 20th bed head down hand
on the shovel
the next morning um
was uh was the
uh was a community garden day
and i wasn't really expecting a lot of
people i showed up at around 9 00 a.m
and no one was there i thought okay okay
that's fine
um
because there was a big party the night
before and i figured everyone was
sleeping in
but around 11 o'clock i see a bunch of
kids in track uniforms coming over to
the garden
and one of the kids comes up to me and
he's like hey george pogba said you guys
needed help building beds so we brought
the track team
i was like okay
sure
and a little while later you see the
baseball team coming over to the garden
and
once again someone comes up and he's
like yeah we heard you guys needed help
everyone was talking about it so we came
to help build beds
by one o'clock all 100 beds were built
and we were two weeks ahead of schedule
that's how it works
that's how things get done when kids are
involved you got high schoolers think
there that's how things get done
sometimes it takes a year to build a
hoop house you thought was going to take
you a week
other times it takes you a day to build
the banjo that would take you a month
i have one last story
last summer
i was i was at an interview at my high
school it wasn't a work day in the
garden so i wasn't working in the garden
but i had to get picked up by my mom and
it's easier for her to pick me up in the
garden so i went down to the garden just
to get picked up
and as i'm walking down
i see a mom and her little kid walking
around the garden
and i thought maybe they were there to
buy a t-shirt or ask for some vegetables
so i went over and asked if they needed
any help
and the mom said oh hi like sorry work
it's just that my son is in the after
school program and um and every time we
drive by the garden he's like mommy
mommy look the garden can we stop and i
never stopped so today i thought i would
stop and let him show me around the
garden like hope you don't mind
and so i said sure no i don't mind i'll
just i'm just waiting for a ride i'm
gonna go sit on the edge of the garden
and uh
and don't mind me
and i realized i recognized the kids his
name is parker haynes and he's a
four-year-old he's in one of the
after-school programs and so i sat on
the edge of the garden and watched as
parker haynes led his mom around the
garden on a tour
well i couldn't see him the whole time
though because every once in a while
he'd disappear under the tomato plants
because he's about this big
and so he's leaving his mom around the
garden and i can hear some of the things
he's saying not everything but some of
the things i can hear him say look mommy
these are my carrots and we plant them
with the with the tomatoes because they
grow well together and look mommy these
are beans and potatoes and i plant them
that way because they're friends
and
and so parker haynes
leads his mom on this tour and finally
she's like she's done with the tour
she's okay all right time to go now and
they they decide to leave the guard
but as they're walking out they're about
to leave and he reaches up and grabs his
mom his mom's hand again and he stops
her
and he looks up at her with this look on
his face it's the look my cousin gets
whenever she tries on a dress and like
asks her mom what it looks like it was
this worried expectancy and parker looks
up at his mom and he says mommy
do you like my garden
i thought about that
and i looked out of this 12 000 square
foot garden
and i looked down at parker haynes
and i realize
he's 100 correct
it is his card
and that's why kids matter the kids
matter because a four-year-old who comes
up to my knee can feel ownership over 12
thousand square foot garden
and a group of high schoolers that every
single adult out there thinks spends the
whole their whole time playing video
games and can't commit to anything a
group of high schoolers can feel
ownership over the world and decide that
they're going to change it and make it
the right place that they want the
future to look like
so the whole time i've been talking i've
had this photo up in the background
and it's a nice photo it's from the
gardens kids sunny day
and that photo sort of captures the
stories
and it's an important story i think it's
a nice story it's the story about
you know the deliciousness of a tasty
vegetable it's just it's a story about
the relaxation of working in a garden on
a sunny day
it's a story i would tell a room full of
little kids
it's a story i would tell a room full of
potential donors
probably even a room full of adults
but uh you guys are a room full of high
schoolers and the story that i want you
to leave today remembering
is this story
um
that's the story of trying to change the
world one carat at a time as tedious and
tiring and painful as it can sometimes
be to work that slowly
it's the story of gardening in the rain
and the snow
and the cold when all you you're just
craving warmth and sunlight and comfort
it's it's the story that if i told my
grandmother that i was gonna
talk to you guys about today she would
be like oh great now none of them are
ever gonna garden in their lives
but i have more faith in youth and kids
than my grandmother does
because i know that it's a story
that we're going to have to live if we
want to change the world and it's the
story that only youth
only us
only us are going to be able to
carry out in order to make change
so four years ago
i started a garden
i've said that sentence so many times
now
and each time i say it the length of
time gets a little longer
so the first time i said you know six
months ago i started a garden
and i was talking about a small 50 by 70
pot at my school
i just finished my freshman year of high
school
and a few weeks ago i graduated
after working in the garden every day
for four years i only have a few weeks
left in the garden
and there are a lot of things i'm proud
about
i'm proud that shawnee rodriguez decides
that he likes sweet peas
i'm proud that the cafeteria workers
know what kohlrabi is
and i'm proud that dozens of other
schools have started project crowds
but the thing i'm most proud of
is that in a few weeks
when i leave projects proud
there won't even be a hiccup in its
operation
and when i come back to visit a few
years down the road no one will
recognize me no one will have any idea
who i am they'll just hand me a shovel
and ask me to start digging
the truth is
i haven't changed the world in the last
four years
but what i've realized
is that if people like george cocophere
keep staying late at the garden to dig
beds
and kids like parker haynes decides that
it's their garden
and all of us
are willing to garden in the rain
then i don't have to change the world
the change will be inevitable
thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu